I'd like to welcome everyone to the
inaugural Norman a Alexander lecture in
Jewish Studies this is sponsored by the
friends of the libraries at Columbia my
name is Jim Neal and I am the university
librarian at Columbia this evening we
celebrate the Norman alexander library
for jewish studies and to honor his
vision and generosity earlier this
evening we dedicated a plaque in the
lobby of butler library to commemorate
his support I remember my visit with mr.
Alexander on october nine two hundred
2006 just about five years ago at his
office on Park Avenue we talked about
his student years at Columbia his love
of the University and his and the role
that a library plays in preserving the
word and the book even if that book was
increasingly not on paper but in digital
form he understood that but I'm not sure
he liked it the gift from mr. Alexander
supported by his family enabled us to
establish three endowments one for the
Norman Alexander librarian for jewish
studies now so effectively filled by
Michelle Chesney a second endowment to
support acquisitions for the general
collections across Columbia's 22
libraries and a third endowment to
support our Rare Book and Manuscript
Holdings including the important judaica
resources and Hebrew manuscripts the
Alexander gift has actually prompted to
additional gifts to the libraries to
support the digitization of our Hebrew
manuscripts including a cooperative
project with the National Library of
Israel the Jewish Studies collections at
Columbia our extensive numbering over
100,000 volumes 1,000 journals plus
important film sound recording microform
and electronic resources Columbia
actually holds 1500 judaica manuscripts
one of the largest collections in the
country including 29
I in kanab Allah and 300 16th century
imprints a very special collection
special collections range from the OCO
gebhardt Spinoza collection to the
papers of such individuals as Herman
Wouk and and Herbert Lehman Columbia is
the only repository in New York for the
visual history archive of the Shoah
foundation and has major oral history
collections on the Yiddish language
slides showing on this monitor
illustrate a small sampling of the
extraordinary range of collections we
have here at Columbia the norman
alexander library of jewish studies
sustains and expands this rich tradition
let us proceed to the lecture dr.
Jonathan Sarna is the joseph h and bell
our brawn professor of American Jewish
history at Brandeis University in 2004
he was named by forward newspaper as one
of the country's 50 most influential
American Jews he was chief historian for
the three hundred and fiftieth
commemoration of the American Jewish
community and is recognized as a leading
commentator on American Jewish history
religion and life in 2009 he was elected
to the american academy of arts and
sciences dr. Sarna received his
doctorate from Yale in 1979 and he has
taught at Yale the University of
Cincinnati the Hebrew University in
Jerusalem and Hebrew Union College he is
chief historian of the National Museum
of American Jewish history in
Philadelphia professor Sarna will speak
tonight on General Grant and the Jews
the election of 1868 and the origin of
Jewish politics in the United States
you'll find on your seat a copy of the
pamphlet which is at the core of his
discussion with us tonight there will be
an opportunity after his talk for some
questions and then a reception at the
back of the room dr. Sarna thank you
very much it is a great pleasure and
privilege to be here it's not in my
official biography but my mother is a
was a very proud alumna of this
university my father taught here for a
few years so I feel very close to to
Columbia and I think that Norman
Alexander's wonderful bequest really
reflects appreciation for the written
word he was among many other things and
I see friend Gary Rosenblatt here a
founder and board member of the Jewish
week here in New York and he really
understood the importance of books and
journals and manuscripts as vehicles for
education for public awareness and of
course for scholarship colombia's
judaica holdings have long been renowned
on I know that personally I spent a
summer here in the early 1980s gathering
material on the history of
jewish-christian relations in the United
States and I feel certain and that under
the leadership of Professor Jeremy
Dalbir and of michael ryan the director
of rare books and michelle chester they
knew Norman Alexander librarian I know
that this library will become even more
influential in the Jewish Studies world
now my subject this evening begins with
this small 16-page pamphlet that you
have on your chair published by the
national news company in New York in
June of 1868 it was entitled with no
effort at subtle thing General Grant and
the Jews and by the way it sold for can
sense
if you know of any copies even if
they're a little more than consents
speak to Michelle Chesney ah my guess is
since this was a political pamphlet that
a great many copies were distributed for
free but of course it was in the nature
of these kinds of pamphlets to disappear
and they're only a small number of
copies that survive today the one that
you have is in the library of congress
now the author of this pamphlet is
listed as one ph Vaughn boy I spent a
great deal of time trying to determine
if I could figure out who this gentleman
was he is otherwise unknown and the
pamphlet is written in the form of an
open letter to General Grant and if you
go to the very end of it you will see
interestingly that it is signed not at
mr. Van port but rather yours obediently
a Jew um now we actually know the names
of a great many of the Jews who lived in
New York in eighteen sixty eight and
there is no van von borcke among them so
it seems safe to assume that actually
all librarians have assumed and it was
assumed at the time but it is a
pseudonym the pamphlet was clearly
authored by one of General Grant
Democratic Party opponents now the
timing of this pamphlet in June of 1868
is no accident for months pundits had
declared that Grant who was a national
hero he general-in-chief of the armies
of the United States that by the way is
a designation higher than that held by
George Washington in the American
Revolution ah
and they had known that he was the
Republican frontrunner in the eighteen
sixty eight election indeed War veterans
meeting in Chicago in eighteen sixty
eight all but demanding that he'd be
selected as the candidate Jessi grant
alyssa's s Grant's father also spoke out
on his son's behalf grant himself was
characteristically silent ah that was
you miss Aoife silent they sometimes
called him I but he certainly knew what
was going on according to his wife who
left us a very interesting memoir only
published in 1975 he told her the
convention is about to assemble I don't
hear that they will nominate me ah and
indeed that is what happened he was
nominated on May the 21st unanimously
and on the first ballot and Schuyler
Colfax who was the speaker the house at
that time became his running mate now
grants nomination posed an unprecedented
problem for America's Jews six years
earlier back on December the 17th 1862
next year is going to be one hundred and
fiftieth anniversary on December the
17th 1862 prior to Vicksburg and his
other what time successes gret in a fit
of anger over smuggling and influence
perhaps by his own father's rather shady
deal with Jewish clothing manufacturers
Harmon Henry and Simon Mac they all had
a conspiracy together to move southern
cotton a northward I getting permits
from Jesse grant son who at this high
position in the military gray
had issued an infamous order known as
General Orders number 11 whose main
paragraph read as follows this is 1862
well the Jews as a class violating every
regulation of trade established by the
Treasury Department and also Department
orders are hereby expelled from the
department within 24 hours from the
receipt of this order the department was
the whole area under grants command as a
result of this order which is the most
anti-semitic official order in all of
American history a small number of Jews
were expelled from the territories in
Mississippi Kentucky and Tennessee that
were under grants command at that time
and more Jews certainly would have been
expelled had not Abraham Lincoln
overturned the order less than three
weeks after it was issued now given the
Emancipation Proclamation and then
grants string of victories fewer over
the order rapidly subsided in 1863
practically nothing more was said about
the order up for the next five years but
now that Brad was a candidate for the
presidency of the United States the
order took on new significance what did
it reveal about the generals character
and qualification for office could Jews
vote for a man national hero who once
had expelled quote Jews as a class from
his war zone and if they didn't vote for
him would this set them apart from the
multitude who viewed grant as the savior
of the unit might it ray
the ugly specter of duel loyalty
suggesting that Jews cared more about
Jewish issues than about the welfare of
the country as a whole now the
Democratic Party had been gaining power
in local and state elections during the
last year of Andrew Johnson's presidency
even grant hometown of Galena Illinois
had elected a Democratic mayor so a
close national election was forecast a
Jewish community 150 200 thousand many
of them women minors or otherwise
ineligible to vote as recent immigrants
might not actually seem of great
political significance Jews were less
than 1% a lot less than 1% of the
population in eighteen sixty eight but
Americans have regularly exaggerated the
size and political power of the jewish
community that was true in eighteen
sixty eight even still true today and in
tight elections as the nation
politically read the ad with the nation
rediscovers periodically when elections
are fight our every vote counts so in a
bid to attract jewish voters democrats
seized on General Orders number 11 their
goal was naturally to cast aspersions on
grand generally and particularly to lure
Jewish Republicans into the Democratic
camp and our pamphlet here General Grant
and the Jews sought to advance that
political goal it opened with the full
text of General Orders number eleven
capitalizing its most Lou
phrases and a challenge grant to enter
to answer whether the document furnished
a guy quote to your character to the
standard of your education to your sense
of justice to your humanity to your
understanding of the foundations on
which the nation has become great to
your qualifications for the presidential
chair instead of searching out the
guilty individuals punishing them and
preventing a repetition of their crime
the pamphlet charge you have condemned
the innocent with the guilty and you
have thus degraded the action of a judge
into a deal of brutal and vindictive
cruelty and then there's a long defence
of the Jewish people which you can read
my homework but the pamphlet then
proceeds really to the impact which is
the most astonishing part of this
document it reads as a class you have
stigmatized and expelled us as if
speaking in the name of every Jew as a
classic continued we rise up and vote
against you like one man and the
pamphlet again in the name of all
American Jews concluded with a bold
almost unprecedented statement of Jewish
power truly remarkable for what it
reveals about American jury optimist
optimistic self-confidence in eighteen
sixty eight but very discomforting to
read today seeing how later anti-semites
would turn such characterizations back
against Jews and accused them of
controlling the destinies of Nations
conclude we are numerous we are
influenced
so we are well fit we are diffused over
the whole continent we are as one family
wherever our influence reaches every Jew
no matter of what political party every
Jew with the vote seekin command will
endeavor to defeat and with God's
blessing will defeat you and with that
our pamphlet concludes but you don't
have to believe everything you read in
every book in the Norman Alexander to
data collection and you need believe
everything in the pamphlet either but it
is an astonishing statement on to have
been penned by someone who who signs
himself a Jew now defeat for the
Republican Party look to be particularly
consequential in 1868 because in the
balance hung the faith of 4 million
Friedman that is underprivileged former
slaves who had benefited politically
socially and economically from the
Reconstruction era policies that
Republicans championed the opposition
Democrats firmly aligned with the white
race promise short policy changes quote
to rescue the country from the anarchy
of radicalism the Negro one prominent
Democratic Party banner red may become a
Republican a slave or a tyrant but never
a Democrat
now against this background
liberal-minded Jews who actually
disagree with the author of General
Grant and the Jews and supported the
Republican Party notwithstanding what he
wrote there were a lot of Jews who
disagreed with him at these Republican
Jews got busy louis n damp it's a noted
louisville attorney and scholar who
courageously opposed slavery and was an
early supporter of Abraham Lincoln today
he is more famous as the uncle and Idol
of future Supreme Court justice Louis
dem vixen Brandeis dimension Brandeis in
every lectures in my contract I'm but
Louis Adam bits um sent a letter of
inquiry concerning General Orders number
eleven to Grant's headquarters and he
received a long and rather courteous
reply from not from grant himself but
from Grant spokesman who told damn bits
what he and other Jewish Republicans
desperately wanted to hear allegations
that the order was issued on account of
the religion of the Jews canna be
seriously entertained by anyone who
knows the general steadfast adherence to
the principles of American liberty and
religious toleration and a rather
similar reply was received by b'nai
brith leader Simon whoop satisfied where
these reassurances dem boots and wolf
notwithstanding over threat in the
pamphlet they came out in support of
grant in fact wolf tirelessly a campaign
on
on grants behalf and later became such
an acolyte that he named his son Adolphe
grant wolf but in any case they proved
in case you had any doubts on the matter
that all Jews were not of one mind when
it came to the election they rarely are
the Jewish banking family led by Joseph
Seligman vez se lehman bank also very
strongly supported grant Salek mins and
the grants had known each other for 20
years the majority of American Jews
however were not nearly so easily won
over observers like the New York Times
which of course was not yet owned by the
oaks family predicted a wholesale
defection of Jews to the Democratic
Party Joseph madill who was a Republican
he was the famous Republican editor of
the Chicago Tribune that's why they
named of famous journalism school after
madill on Joseph madill believed that
the Jews of Cincinnati and st. Louis st.
Louis are numerous enough to defeat our
ticket in both cities and they are
strong enough to hurt us in Chicago also
as they include many of our active
Republicans unless grant put the issue
of General Orders number 11 to rest with
a strong public statement madill warned
we shall lose large number of jew votes
besides converting them into very active
bitter opponents now grant himself later
admitted to having received hundreds of
letters from Jews inquiring about his
order refusing to budge from his
principles quote I thought it would be
better to adhere to the rule of silence
to all letters he answered none of them
as a result just as madill had feared
the Democrats bustled about making a
political weapon of grants expulsion
order in all parts of the country now
another book is larger and we might have
given a piece of it here but it follows
from this pamphlet the Democratic
speakers handbook prepared by the party
in those days political parties would
prepare speakers and books for on their
supporters so they could run around and
use the handbook as a kind of pony for
giving speeches so the Democratic
speakers handbook prepared by the party
for its loyal supporters trumpeted this
weapon of grants aunty Jewish order it
devoted three double column small print
pages to quote General Grant on our
Hebrew fellow citizens recounting the
episode to the both of Democrats who
actually one suspect nothing about it
the section concluded with lines that
the handbook likely expected party
speakers on every stump to echo quote
violating trade in be why that order was
violated everywhere no the Jews were
persecuted because they were Jews and
nothing else I suspect whenever you hear
historians say I suspect it means I
haven't found the proof yet but I
suspect but cannot prove that the
Democrats were somewhat influenced by
the longtime chair of the Democratic
National Committee its financier august
belmont Feldman was thoroughly
Americanized he was married to the
daughter
of commodore matthew perry and he raised
his children as Episcopalians but his
enemies still frequently reminded him
that he was a quote foreign-born jus so
he understood as well as any politician
of his day that the Jewish issue could
be a potent weapon in the Democrats
campaign arsenal I for a while wondered
whether Belmont himself hasn't been
behind this pamphlet Thord man board
Belmont but I haven't found any key
there that allows me to say anything
about that in any case the Democratic
Party ticket highlighted the National
divide at the Democratic candidate in
1868 was a good New Yorker Horatio
Seymour at the former governor of this
state he actually had uphold the
Emancipation Proclamation are and the
vice president oh but he supported the
city supported the Union in the Civil
War II opposed the Emancipation
Proclamation and the Vice President was
Francis p Blair of Missouri a border
state senator he also had supported the
Civil War but he now promised voters
that if elected he would quote prevent
the people of our race from being driven
out of the country or trodden under foot
by an inferior and semi barbarous race
ah you get a sense of what was at stake
in eighteen sixty eight and the rhetoric
that was used on so the 1868 election
really becomes something of a national
referendum on reconstruction and black
suffrage and that upped the ante for
Jews who choked at the thought of voting
for Ulysses
grant but strongly supported Republican
policies on reconstruction and they face
for the first time but not to my mind
for the last time a very difficult
conundrum should they vote for a party
that they considered bad for the country
just to avoid voting for a man who had
been bad to the Jews and the closer the
election drew the more heated rhetoric
within the Jewish community became Simon
wolf who ever said was a big grand
supporter a leader in b'nai brith an
important lawyer in a widely reprinted
letter insisted Jews should always vote
their principles however awarded grants
order might have been that is no reason
he exclaimed why American citizen should
be betrayed from their allegiance to
principles and turn to a party that
advocated the reverse of what is right
and true by contrast Moses Ezekiel of
Richmond on he's a Confederate veteran
but many in this audience may know him
as a silk dirty producer the all parade
of Confederate sculptures including a
famous one in arlington on and and he
and monuments and and he insisted the
jewish religious principles as he
understood them required in her vote
against grant quote the jew who does not
with all his foot sole and means oppose
the election of this second pharaoh he
wrote deserves to be publicly branded as
a renegade to his faith
he is there actually echoing what our
author here general grant from the Jews
also stated now unprecedented empty
grant public gatherings also would help
this never happened before 1868 I they
were held by Jews in memphis and
nashville and atlanta and st. Louis and
Los Angeles Atlanta's Jewish merchants
erected a whole transparency on white
wall street that proclaimed the Jews
will defeat grant as they defeated Haman
the Jews will elevate grant to office
you got to know your Bible to understand
this the Jews will elevate grant to
office as they elevated Heyman I'm
payment with her after those who don't
remember their Purim story and the book
of Esther never before had a miracle
witnessed such a public display of
political power on the part of its
Jewish citizens and actually from the
perspective of modern Jewish history the
whole discussion of Julie power and the
Jewish vote is fascinating any many ways
transformative are in the wake of their
political emancipation in Europe many
western and central Jews had come to ask
you the exercise of Jewish power through
group politics of any sort indeed
Sephardic Jews in London in 1648 went so
far as to threaten excommunication to
anyone who voted in an election or took
sides on a political question and even
after they received their rights as a
group often in the form of special
legislations
a Jew Bell Jews were expected to
exercise those rights if it all soli and
individuals the last thing they wanted
to do was to stir up old anti-semitic
charges that Jews formed a state within
a state caring more about their fellow
Jews than about their country so as to
protect their rights as individual Jew
as individual views over several
centuries learn to piously insist that
they no longer voted on the basis of any
interest that they shared with other
Jews now in America where of course the
Constitution treats juices equals and
Jews are not mentioned at all in the
Constitution immigrant Jews nevertheless
tended to follow the same carefully
nurtured modern European political
habits and really for unwritten rules of
proper Jewish political behavior were
commonly preached by this was really set
down for us by Professor Naomi Cohen who
famously taught a course of American
American Jewish history and practically
all american jewish historians of a
certain age not including me studied
with her at this university and she
trained them all and one of the things
she trained them were about these four
rules of proper Jewish political
behavior what Jews may not ban together
in separate political clubs two rabbis
or lay leaders have no right to advise
the community on how to vote three
Jewish agencies must not use their
influence to promote Jewish aspirants to
public office and for Jews may not
support a candidate just because he
happens to be Jewish
now during the 1868 election those who
preached those laws in public violated
them with impunity in private and
sometimes in public as well but actually
to them and their descendants really
well into the 20th century Jewish
politics the raw exercise of Jewish
power in this remarkable pamphlet
actually became something akin to sexual
intercourse practiced openly it was
embarrassing and shameful done
discreetly behind closed doors it was
natural and legitimate that by the way
is the only sex you're going to get in
this lecture so make the most of it um
but that really explains why some of the
most politically active Jews including
Simon wolf or some years later the great
Jewish lawyer Louis Marshall vigorously
insisted that there's no such thing as
Jewish group politics even though they
actively engaged in group politics
behind the scenes then as now many did
not practice what they preached now the
more vexing questions raised in 1868 and
no less relevant today where I think the
questions of multiple loyalties those
who injected General Orders number 11
into the campaign like our author of
General Grant and the Jews plainly
sought to appeal to Jewish voters on the
basis of their special interest in
Jewish issues but was it legitimate for
Jews to base their votes on such
considerations or in selecting a
presidential candidate should
us as voters cast aside all special
interests and only consider the national
interest more to the point should
General Orders number 11 single-handedly
determine how JEWS vote for aught
responsible voters to weigh up the
totality of issues facing the country
before making up their minds two of
America's most distinguished reform
rabbis debated these very issues in the
newspapers liepman Adler the rabbi of
chicago's oldest synagogue kam it's now
one block away from president obama's
house argued against voting on the basis
of Jewish interests and in favor of what
he considered broad American interest he
was very proud of being a Jew but he
explained it is different when I take a
ballot in order to exercise my rights as
a citizen then I am NOT a Jew but I feel
an active a citizen of the Republic on
Election Day insisted do not ask what
pleases the Israelites I consult the
welfare of the country so much did his
responsibilities as a citizen outweigh
those of being a Jew that he
provocatively declared that he would
vote even for the party of Haman which
of course the Republican Party was in
the eyes of many Jewish Democrats if he
believed that that party would do the
most for the welfare of the country and
the advancement of human rights I'll
read you this long quote it is unique in
the animal
of even of rabbinic rhetoric quote if
that party in whose hands i believe the
welfare of the country so far as the
advancement of human rights was
concerned was the safest were to place a
Heyman at the helm of state and if the
opposite party whose non-existence I
believe would be better for Humanity and
my country would a place Messiah at the
head make Moses the Chief Justice and
call the patriarchs to the cabinet I
should say raspar under Haman my
fatherland and here you have my vote
even if all the jew in me Moritz not too
many rabbis I think wouldn't go quite
that far in case anyone missed the
biblical metaphor rabbi adler declared
forthrightly if grant is the best man
for the Americans he is the best man for
us Israelites despite general order
number 11 a direct response to our
pamphlet rabbi Isaac mayor wise the
great reform Jewish leader could not
have disagreed more if wrong is wrong p
who defended his wicked wise acidly
wrote in condemning those who advocated
for grants election and in reply to
people like Adler who raised the specter
of multiple loyalties wise insisted in
real life could not so easily be
compartmentalized it is a piece of
sophistry he declared to suggest that
one should be the one half of himself
wise concluded that responsible voters
needed to weigh up their
responsibilities Jews and as citizens
at one and the same time we bring both
the Jew and the citizen to the public
forum and to the synagogue before our
God and our country defending his focus
on General Orders number 11 wise
insisted that civil and religious
liberty is a sacred boom which must be
protected against each and every
aggression we must speak and act
according to the very dictates of
conscience and convention now actually
no final decision ever resolved this
debate it arises a new like the Phoenix
every time some Jewish issue most
recently support for Israel intrudes
into the presidential campaign the same
intensity many of the same arguments
only differences in detail distinguish
the debates in Grant's day from those in
our own then as now the tensions in
current in the term American Jew
embracing responsibilities to country
and to fellow Jews heighten the
challenge of casting a presidential
ballot nor are Jews by the way alone in
facing this dilemma parallel tensions
face members of almost every ethnic
religious and special interest groups
weighing up competing claims
establishing priorities among one's
principles and concerns and reaching a
decision about whom to support can make
voting whether in eighteen sixty eight
or 2012a an excruciating ly difficult if
deeply self-revealing process now back
in eighteen sixty eight many pundits
expected that after weighing
balancing all of these different factors
the majority of American Jews would vote
against ulysses s grant and in favor of
Horatio Seymour uh even though he had
the name gmorn work that had no play
whether they did so in fact or not we
will never know what we do know is the
grant emerged the winner in 1868 by
three hundred and nine thousand five
hundred and eighty four votes and a
healthy 134 electoral vote margin except
perhaps here in New York where grant
lost by precisely ten thousand votes and
fraud as long been suspected the Jewish
vote ugh certainly did not make much
difference in the election Ohio and
Pennsylvania two states where Jewish
voters were supposed to help the
Democrats both went Republican by
comfortable margins the vote in Indiana
was closer but the Jewish vote in
Indiana was too small to make a
difference actually as the great
historian John Hope Franklin observed
years ago the more than half a million
african-american votes cast especially
in the south much of most of which
naturally went to grant made much more
of a difference in the totals they may
actually as well the election in Grant's
failure now a fitting epilogue to the
tumultuous battle for the Jewish vote
appeared in newspapers across the
country during the final weeks of
november in 1868 that's after the
election and with the election behind
him ulysses s grant in a published
letter told jews just what they wanted
to hear from the president-elect whoa i
do not pretend to sustain the order Jews
were especially thrilled with grants
forthright unambiguous
and appropriately italicized concluding
declaration in that letter quote I have
no prejudiced against sect or race but
want each individual to be judged by his
own merit order number 11 does not
sustain this statement I admit but then
I do not sustain that order it never
would have been issued if it had not
been telegraphed the moment it was
penned and without reflection after
months of bitter internecine political
battling Jews cheerfully United in
praise of grants quote noble and
generous letter and I think
understandably so by declaring that I do
not sustain that order grant confessed
misdeed and allied with values that in
the civil wars wake liberal Americans
cherished above all others freedom for
all malice toward none prejudice toward
jews the president-elect had come to
understand was as unacceptable as
prejudice toward blacks in atoning his
letter articulated a higher vision for
Americans quote i want each individual
to be judged by his own never as
president and then for the remainder of
his life grant actually tried to act in
accord with that declaration this is in
the Jewish calendar the ten days of
repentance and true repentance is not
only what you say but what you do and
grant lived up to that to that idea he
as President appointed more Jews to
public office than all previous American
presidents combined went out of his way
to promote human rights for Jews in
Russia and romania by the
of his life by death in 1885 he had
actually become a hero to America's Jews
and his death was deeply mourned in
synagogues across the land so the story
of General Grant and the Jews trudeau
very differently I telescope did but you
can read my book in a few months and I
go on for three chapters on on grant uh
as president and in his
post-presidential years but the story
turned out very differently than our
pseudonymous 1868 pamphleteer expected
over the last 17 years of his life from
1868 until his death grant transformed
himself from an enemy of the jews to
their friend from Haman to Mordecai from
a general who expelled Jews as a class
to a president who embraced Jews as
individuals in which respect the
election of ulysses s grant in 1868 the
whole subject of this pamphlet marked
among many other things a political
coming-of-age for American Jews it
engaged them as Jews in the political
arena and opened up questions concerning
their political responsibilities that
remain unresolved on to our time should
Jews vote for a party they consider bad
for the country just to avoid voting for
a man who had been bad or might be bad
for the Jews that question inspired by
General Grant and the Jews back in
eighteen sixty eight
remains I think surprisingly relevant
today thank you very much
professor Sarna I'm Gail Alexandra
Benjamin and I just wanted to thank you
for delivering the inaugural lecture at
the Normandy alexander library for
jewish studies at Columbia you have not
only set an example but a standard for
everyone to follow and thank you very
much for being here grants of vice
presidential candidate Schuyler Colfax
has gone down in history as the person
who got the first rabbi to make a
invocation at the House of
Representatives but which was sort of
out of keeping with his own background
because he sort of flirted with the
know-nothings at an earlier point so
it's kind of a two-fold question one is
was Cole faxes approach to the Jews in
1860 was that ever used in the campaign
on the side of grant and the other
question is leaving aside Jews as Jews
well almost all the Jews in that era
were immigrants and with anthem
aggression sentiment was just the
general concept of immigration rights at
all an issue at that time was
responsible for that so and you have to
come to columbia to see that could be
reminded not i have a footnote on that
matter and I it's absolutely true and we
have the correspondence it was published
by Bertram corn I know children give it
a prairie for Congress is clear this
i disremember by one of his own
constituents and why not colfax and
response to that constituent was a voter
I noticed why not enemy is possible of
the fact required without was the
American rabba rabba rabba that's
equally lived around England alexa vega
determination and nervous about speaking
english in such a form replica fallon
plugin to give that prayer and indeed he
does so required in the coming I'm
commercial and there's much discussion
about it Becky is that rare but possible
thing is that making 60k particles one
person who knew what you know about
Botox I did find one first
run across any reference to that issue
John thank you so much for that
magnificent lecture I wonder whether you
could tell us the number of Jews that
we're in the we're voting Jews or number
of Jews in the country in eighteen sixty
eight and give us some sense of where
they were located I think you did
mention that they were one percent or
less of the population but can you give
us some numbers in location
Oh a lot of immigrants number of voters
but they're there for exaggeration power
oh the number of Jews so you have people
who will be there whenever I say work
you get Americans today she was Louis
learning our influence you would
I mania which was that has now the
nature of Pennsylvania State for any
presidential campaign to improve of
urban Pennsylvania holla important to
get numbers of Jews that delicate woman
growing community its variants of Jews
so I what's fun about yet but we're
growing numbers of Jews in san francisco
by today's secret of american history x
a second largest
yeah yeah could you say a word about the
demographics of the Jewish population in
the 1860s were they not as substantially
of German origin that is German Jews and
doesn't that make a difference
politically speaking when not that many
years later we get a huge influx of
Eastern European Jews and their position
towards the slavery issue towards
business towards is quite different
possibly than the Eastern European Jews
who had arrived later so be right I
prefer speaking to the Central European
as Germany largely were sent to your
beliefs or the Hat Jews older Sephardic
Jews over the early choose a westerner
as well this is that nobody in the 19th
century assume that all except for this
pamphlet that all choose voted through
one party indeed well in my century are
truthful he divided Republican Democrat
and shoot back was immensely if our
Republican in the late 19th century as
stirrer Democrats avoid me election
Almighty well whenever love you did I
make an accurate calendar and they are
very taken with the Wilson each really
only be a sniveler
in 1920 1200 mpr elections and they are
definitely writing for the easter in
truth we have set of shoes well they
almost Olympic dinner i NVR 10 single
exception of jimmy carter ah there's no
product presidential candidate gets less
than century whenever president
with our European Jews or but we do in
change
so this is a question more relating to
current events um do you see the grant
situation really analogous to the
situation going on now with Jewish
voters voting for certain candidates
that are necessarily pro-israel or less
pro-israel because it just seems to me
that like from my understanding is that
the Israel issue is a bit more
fundamental to Jewish identity than
certain American Jewish issues so if you
could just comment so you're clearly a
very discerning listener lastly
both twelve election and okay incision
you can see was the issues of compassion
are highly contemporary never happen
before actually and that's why I issue
that I don't know the moment when they
were debated drive a little issue
questions on the date on my finger still
with us and I actually think that there
are other way interesting parallels with
the selection how much below I would be
easy as well to differences liar you
know anything could ever ever even
scholars of God seen animal
it's following up on that in view of the
tension that does that exists between
those Jews who wanted to maintain a kind
of national identity if you will if you
were the tension that might have existed
between the Jews who wanted to maintain
some sort of national identity and those
who wanted to be part of the community
more assimilated what trace somewhat the
rise of the Jewish pressure group if you
will was there a what was the feeling as
well you might say what a pack is today
the development from when they would not
appear when they would question that we
again take a whole separate lecture I
will say the total world would to the
major Jewish organizations if they were
they believe in working behind the
scenes say what to study the American
Jewish Committee American Jewish
Committee sure who's engaged politically
but it generally work behind the scenes
and there are such a great affection for
them why don't you succeeded in one they
fail one was an effort to Russia which
shoes strongly supported calf and
business leaders posted you supporting
it in the belief that this would rather
tricky who did that and with a statement
about America human rights oh and you
have a anatomy of advantage of President
cat penis and entry without a day of the
other politically they lose and
traumatize them and that was
you prevent immigration restriction
shoes were tremendously active ever
immigration restrictions you need the
Jews who persecuted in any country and
your partner providing no I had John
snack on impact and they require fewer
exceptions are tripping and as a result
in the nineteen thirty there if you
choose to make it to this country go
another cut the chump that loss
politically let me get you one speak out
above Jews are travelpod and done and
after these why are given the 87th of
the erosion problem or more interested
in developing better America but
understand that
consequence is only in a pogrom period
partly as a result of changes for
American politics rights movement other
movement really in response to the show
ha and the sense that perhaps that you'd
be more publicly and completely love
with different than me shoes merging
that in politics and organization an
impact earth and group politics letter
to black with it or keep artists that
kind of politics become much more
acceptable on emergency than we see a
lot of an idea that Julie political
moves American flammable in need to
remain
the idea be acceptable although i think
issues and questions remain but still
need to the whole subject is sensitivity
study area behavior and five scholars
studied American be taken up
listening to the lecture tonight I
remember fondly the joy of being a
student in sitting into the classroom
and listening a week after week two
wonderful lectures like Professor Sarna
you are extraordinary thank you one of
my responsibilities you know everyone at
Columbia has other duties as assigned my
other duties as assigned is
responsibility for the Bancroft prize
this is the award given each year to the
best books in American history and when
I conclude that that ceremony that
dinner each year I note that the winners
brought some important qualities to
their work solid research well presented
evidence provocative ideas and clarity
of presentation we received that tonight
in the lecture from some from Professor
Sarna he noted his book I will I will I
will say it for him it is being
published by shock and next book later
this year it is called when General
Grant expelled the jews of the
importance of title in selling books i
think but lastly up next to lastly i
want to once again thank norman
alexander and the norman alexander
family for their extraordinary support
for jewish studies and the libraries at
columbia we are here tonight celebrating
that great gift and the enormous
benefits that will accrue to future
generations of students faculty and
researchers at the university thank you
very much to the Alexander family
and let me say one last thing and quote
Somerset Maugham he wants advised that
at a reception one should eat and drink
wisely but not too well and speak well
but not too wisely and so I encourage
you to stay for the reception as we SAT
here a wonderful kosher buffet was moved
into the back of the room so we hope
you'll stay a few minutes have a bite to
eat something to drink and share the
experience a professor saunas talk with
each other thank you for being here